ataque a la mayor central nuclear de
europa en sabor y a ucrania ha hecho que
ambas partes se culpen mutuamente
hoy los ocupantes crearon otra situación
muy peligrosa para todos en europa
bombardearon la central nuclear de
saborío y la han hecho dos veces en un
día esta es la central nuclear más
grande de nuestro continente y cualquier
bombardeo es un delito flagrante un acto
terrorista
rusia tiene que asumir la
responsabilidad solo por crear una
amenaza para la planta de energía
nuclear como tal
a esto se les pidió a toda la comunidad
internacional que sancione a toda la
industria nuclear rusa mientras tanto
moscú ha atribuido el ataque a su
enemigo y lo describe como una descarga
de artillería ucraniana las fuerzas
rusas se apoderaron de la planta de la
ciudad vecina en marzo y según los
servicios de inteligencia británicos sus
intenciones respecto a la planta siguen
sin estar claras aunque está bajo
control ruso el funcionamiento diario de
la planta ha quedado en manos de
técnicos ucranianos pero se sospecha que
rusia utiliza la central nuclear como
una base militar desde la que pueden
disparar con la seguridad de que los
ucranianos no se arriesgarían a
devolverlos paros a un objetivo de este
tipo hace tiempo que se teme que las
acciones rusas puedan provocar una
catástrofe nuclear a gran escala
por supuesto es muy peligroso podría ser
otro chernóbil incluso algo peor los
habitantes de la zona no son los únicos
que están preocupados incluso antes del
bombardeo la agencia internacional de
energía atómica llevaba varias semanas
intentando realizar una inspección de la
planta pero la parte ucraniana no está
dispuesta por temor a que esto legitime
la ocupación rusa el director general
del organismo de vigilancia nuclear
rafael grossi subrayó que probablemente
se estaban violando todos los principios
fundamentales para el funcionamiento
seguro de una central nuclear